[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, I'm Athanasia Mowinckel,
but everyone just calls me Me.
And today, I'd like to talk to
you about how I made a package,
and in that process,
made some friends.
So to know a little
bit about me,
I have a background
in psychology
with a specialization
in neuroimaging.
And in this field,
there's quite a lot of us
who do a lot of coding but we
have no formal training in it,
so sharing our code
is kind of scary.
At least for me, it was
completely out of the question
putting my scripts
publicly online.
I would just share them with
my closest collaborators.
I mean, why is it so scary
to put your scripts online?
Well, you have this idea that
other people know what they're
doing so when they
see your code,
they're just going to think
it's like this sloppy mess that
is completely useless.
And they're just going to throw
all these negatives at you.
And in the end, the
end message will
come that you have no business
doing what you're doing,
and it's terrifying.
But that changed a
little bit over time.
And that started when
my colleague Didac
approached me and asked me if
we could plot brains ggplot2.
So I'm obsessed with ggplot2.
I plot everything
in it if I can.
Or I force myself
to plot everything
in it no matter what.
So he had this idea.
And he just turned
around and made it happen
and suddenly we had
brains in ggplot2.
And it was like this--
it was such a cool process to
be able to create our stats
and immediately
project them onto areas
of the brain in a way that
we were put into publication
had not been able to
do that R before.
And I thought it's not just
R labs that needs this.
We have international
colleagues that we know also
could use something like this.
So maybe this is a
time to figure out
how to share your code.
So Didac
gave me his script.
And I turned the
script into a function.
And I took that one function,
turned into many functions
in a package.
And I shipped the
package off to GitHub.
And I was terrified.
Excited, but terrified of
what people would think.
But it turns out I
didn't have to be.
Because people started
tweeting about it like,
Mara started tweeting about
it, and other neuroscientists
that I respect a lot
started tweeting
about the package
being really good and easy to
use, giving them pretty plots.
And suddenly, all this
unequivocally positive feedback
that I'd never gotten
in academia before.
It was so exciting
and thrilling.
And it was so much fun having
made something that was useful.
I never had anything
useful before.
And it was just so cool.
The next thing that
happened was even cooler,
because people started doing
pull requests to our packages.
People we didn't
know from before
and they helped us improve
the efficiency of our functions,
making sure they passed
R command checks,
adding unit tests.
I had never heard of unit test,
sorry, before that PR came.
And suddenly, I was
obsessed about writing
unit tests for everything.
And this user, John
Shelly from Johns Hopkins,
he helps us prepare our
package to be included
in the neuro conductor,
which is a bio
conductor for neuroimaging
that we didn't even know
existed before this.
And suddenly, we were connected
to this network of R developers
for neuroimaging that
we didn't know before.
And we have this
reciprocal community.
And it's so extremely cool.
And now, I'm not so scared
about sharing my code
and putting it online.
I do it quite often in my
blog, and in the multitude
of packages I've made
since that first one.
It's just nice to connect with
people who do and appreciate
the same things you do.
So make a package and
make some friends.